moving on to some Home Entertainment
Tonight is the second season premiere of
CSI Vegas and Mark helgenberg hellenberg
helgenberger
is back as Catherine Williams over the
summer Jason with the cast while they
were filming a scene at Circa to chat
about the upcoming season and Mark's big
return
oh this is such a pleasure to have you
on the show and it's how are you really
good congratulations on the success of
season one what did you think of season
one you know what it's like it's like
what did I say my children adjacent over
there was like it's like being building
a building a plane as you're taking off
from a Runway you know what I mean
because there's a lot of stuff we get to
learn how to do science we get to learn
how to say really intense words we've
got to be part of an amazing franchise
that has such you know amazing fan base
it's it's it's an absolute pleasure
season one was amazing what can we
expect in season two well I know there's
some surprises that we saw here today
anything else in store for season two I
can't give you everything okay but
little tidbits I can tell you more about
we get to learn about the Twisted
Twisted stuff that that viewers fell in
love with you know that that drives the
show episode to episode the different
ways of that people you know find
to harm one another and how we figure it
out this is my lovely showrunner he's
meant he looks really normal but he
thinks of some really twisted stuff yeah
Jason do you come up with all the
twisted stuff yeah we got a whole team
of Twisted people to come up with a
twisted stuff here's the thing this is
why I'm conflicted I love the show and
these exterior shots it makes Las Vegas
look amazing but an outsider looking in
I'm thinking the madness that happens in
this town because of you I apologize but
I love the city the show's an Ode to the
great crazy stuff that can happen in
this town you know I kind of feel like
there's something you're not telling me
be a very sharp Max
I think we're going to enjoy working
together Mark what are you doing here on
set
I'm trying to be cool you know we're so
excited that you are back
[ __ ] you thank you it's I've heard that
from you know
many people it always is nice here that
you
know I stopped watching when you left
and you know that kind of thing but
um so yeah I mean it's it's fun to kind
of come back after all these years you
know we shot the pilot in 2000. 22 years
ago
and um just to see how the character has
grown she's gotten wiser she's how much
has stayed the same but I think you know
like that's the fun thing about doing a
series is you get to see how the
character evolves there's always highs
and lows and and um you know to continue
his life you know it's continuation of
this person's life it's like everyone's
life what can we expect from your
characters here in season two you're
back which is huge I mean we're geeking
out the fact that you're here yeah
you're gonna see the signature Captain
stuff you know see her you know her
toughness or her passion her
intelligence her uh tenacity you know
all of those things are gonna be like
almost out from the gate you'll see that
foreign
[Music]
catch the season two premiere of CSI
Vegas tonight right here on channel
eight